oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god this is the bad
place i [ __ ] knew it
and clam chowder is disgusting it's just
hot ocean milk with dead animal croutons
well what do we do panic freak i usually
panic but i am happy to free we need a
plan
i say we just lie low and hope that they
don't notice me i'm sorry i don't think
i can help you i just don't like being
dishonest and
i can't advise you to be dishonest
either come on i'm just asking you to
fudge a little bit
you must have told a few white lies in
your life i mean what was your job
i was a professor of ethics and moral
philosophy
mother forker i'm getting a stomachache
i'm in a perfect utopia and i have a
stomachache i am
absolutely paralyzed by decision making
and it is destroying my life
yeah i sort of got that when you
couldn't choose a chair to sit on well
i didn't want to offend you in case you
had a favorite morning chidi blu-ray
muffin for you
uh i don't know maybe i can't decide
you're right there mate okay
i've made my decision i want to
start crying
here we are just press that button and
it's
goodbye janet chidi
i can see that you're worried and i just
want to assure you i am not human
and i cannot feel pain ah thank you that
helps
however i should warn you i am
programmed with a fail-safe measure
as you approach the kill switch i will
begin to beg for my life
it's just there in case of an accidental
shutdown but it will seem
very real cool so who's doing this me or
you
oh well i i think i have to um being a
bystander seems worse
somehow okay here we go
jenny no no no shitty please please
please don't hurt me i don't want to die
please
again i am not human i can't die
i am simply an anthropomorphized vessel
of knowledge
built to make your life easier your
pleading
seems so real oh yes it is a very
effective fail-safe what do you guys
think the bad place is going to be for
you
i'll probably go to a skrillex concert
and i'll be waiting for the bass drop
and it
it'll never come for me it'll be camping
like i'll just always be camping i'm
pretty good at
turning every place i go and into my
personal hell so
i think they'll have a lot of options
for me you are
i mean no no don't say anything don't do
it one or two i want i want to
here's the thing about me you know the
sound that a fork makes
in the garbage disposal that's the sound
that my brain makes
all the time it's just this constant
grinding about things i'm afraid of or
things that i want or or want to want
or or want to want to there's grinding
in there right now bud yep
okay here's the thing that balloon wants
us to be the best version
of ourselves but for the four of us
that's not just a metaphor there have
been
literally 802 different versions
of us and how do i know that this
version is the best version of myself
how do i know
it's not version number 85 or 322 or 558
or 69 or 420. yeah and then you get into
the whole idea of of consciousness and
then just forget about
best and what version of chidi is even
real what happens here does he
eventually tie himself i don't
usually but this one seems to be getting
stronger as he goes on cheese and and
and this chitty is an imposter
my whole life has been uh a torture
chamber
of indecision normally our omniscient
system
perfectly analyzes each person's profile
and then matches him
or her with another person but in your
case the system matched you with two
other people it's a rare occurrence like
uh
like a double rainbow or someone on the
internet
saying you know what you've convinced me
i was wrong
so how do you choose who i should be
with oh i don't choose you do cheat it's
i i'm what this is angelique
pedro and pavita according to the system
either pedro or chidi could be matched
perfectly with either angelique or
pavita so
figure it out should be fun
cool beans one second guys um so
so so yeah so making decisions
isn't necessarily my strong suit i know
that buddy
you you once had a panic attack at a
make your own sunday bar
there were too many toppings and very
early in the process you had to commit
to a chocolate palette or a fruit
palette and if you couldn't decide you
wound up with kiwi junior mint raisin
and just ruins everyone's night
chidi cheatster what's uh happenin
buddy you have a crazy look in your eye
and you're retreating into your shirt
you're kinda
like turtling hey wine
hmm um do i feel like red or white oh
deep down in your heart of hearts you
probably already know which one you want
why isn't anyone talking jenna could you
show me to the bar please
oh hey chidi right denise
we met earlier remember oh yeah hi
are you limping yeah i am crazy story
see i was a trapeze artist in an illegal
circus in bangladesh anjalik
hey how are you doing oh well uh
you know um stomachs and nods i'm
stressed grinding my teeth
and it feels like my soul is being
suffocated you know just your standard
paradise stuff
hi guys um hey can we talk
yeah i need to tell you a secret i uh
i can't
no no guys guys not now
i spent my whole life on earth battling
a stomachache because i never knew
what to do and for a while here that was
gone but recently
i've been miserable why chidi you're in
the good play i know
but i i have this problem and if i
choose option a
oh but if i choose option b
oh no you know chidi
sometimes adversity can lead to growth
whatever the moral dilemma is maybe
you'll come out on the other side better
for it
yeah no i'm i'm used to moral dilemmas i
like
moral dilemmas they're my jam but this
just feels like i'm
what like i'm being punished somehow
and obviously i know that silly this is
the good place you two would never do
anything to hurt anyone but i am
seriously
worried that i did something wrong and
this is the universe getting back at me
oh no wow wait what's what's happening
now
oh no no no no no no i i made god
cry oh sorry welcome back old friend
i'm not sure what will work with sean
but we should have all our bases covered
shall we start with the greeks or would
you prefer the modern british
masters chidi
i'm sorry choices are hard for me when
i'm under pressure
what the hell is this the dot over the
eye the hell is that okay
um how do i explain this concisely this
is tuesdays and also july
and sometimes it's never that's true
occasionally that moment on the bear me
timeline
is the time moment when nothing
never occurs so
you get it this broke me the
the dot over the eye that broke me i'm
i'm done this is your ventromedial
prefrontal cortex
the center of decision making this is
where the magic happens
do you see how it's all lit up that's a
flurry of activity that occurred when i
asked you to choose between red and blue
and you always passed out is it too late
to pick blue instead
it is attention i have been murdered
okay dude crash course and getting away
with bad stuff you have to act calm
and cool like you don't have a care in
the world okay
great oh wow look it's weekend at
bernie's
cause you're a dead guy in sunglasses we
have fun don't we chidi
i've never been more stressed out in my
entire life henry i feel
amazing i am 100 pages into my new
thesis and it is some of the best
writing
that i have ever done i haven't been
this happy since
oh wow i've never been happy huh
bad i need to step outside
for some air and i will not be back
for many days dude you can't just run
away
you have to oh
this one looks just like the one i had
when i was a little kid he's so
cute but is is this
a little cuter i mean this pup looks
friskier but this one looks a little
sweeter
maybe oh it's cheating kryptonite choice
between any two things
settle in lizard this is gonna be a
while i mean
should i take the cutest puppy or is
that shallow and is it even okay
to separate them are they brother and
sister or or perhaps
married dude they're heaven puppies i'm
sure they're both incredible just
choose one you're right the black one
that was my first impulse and that is
the one i'll take
i'm so sorry chidi both puppies have
been taken yeah i should have seen that
coming
my indecision has once again cost me
happiness and i will now
suffer the consequences
you